check for your knob and if you can find
a knob it's a door hey all you wrong
side of the bed folks this is WWE
Superstar and the voice of Ferdinand
John Cena here with lad Bible I'm here
to give you a pep talk to get that glass
half full eat glitter for breakfast and
shine all day I think the word shine
should be replaced with something else
because glitter probably is not good for
the digestive system so if you do in
fact eat glitter for breakfast you
probably won't shine all day but
something that exits your body will most
likely shine which can be good don't
practice until you get it right practice
until you don't get it wrong but you
know the deals 10,000 hours of mastery
it's just time under tension basic
equation if we didn't have thumbs we
could never enjoying a sandwich
speechless
don't say the sky's the limit and
there's footprints on the moon or is
there
we'll learn the conspiracy if the door
doesn't open it's not a door wrong the
door could be locked to be someone on
the other side pushing the door so it's
not able to open it could be a doorstop
rusty hinges that it'd be required that
we D be 40 years some other hinge
lubricants check for knobs check for
your knob and if you can find a knob
it's a door
this one's from me personally to all of
you it's easy never give up I have
failed tens of thousands of times and
have only had a few limited true success
tones and the reason I've got to the
finish line
only a few times through all that failed
because through that failure I get back
up dust off the old jacket back in the
fight
[Music]
so there you have it words of
inspiration and wisdom from everyone
including myself if your day isn't
brighter I haven't done my job and I'm
officially fired but if it is don't
attack the day I mean
[Music]